[Music]
hi everyone
i'm catherine i'm really excited to talk
to you today about we are our ladies
which is
the roll curve for our ladies global
what is a roelker you ask
good question a roker is a rotating
curation account which means that
there's a rotating spokesperson for a
given social media account
and this is pretty intuitive for an
organization like our ladies because we
have 180 plus chapters worldwide
and there are so many awesome people
doing such amazing things
so every week we have a different person
curate or tweet from
we are our ladies they discuss their
experiences they
discuss how they use our and maybe some
tips and tricks along the way
since this account started in august
2018 we've gained 15 000
plus followers we've had 56 awesome
curators across 19 different countries
and hopefully there's more to come in
2020. this picture on the left is
actually our very first tweet from
our first curator ever which was mara
avrick
so if we look at the most frequently
used words from tweets
in this account you'll see that it looks
very similar to what you might see on
the rstats hashtag
things like data package code however
for every technical topic that we
that we speak about curators are really
generous about
talking about their experiences they're
talking about what they love their
community
their learning journeys and i think this
is really what makes this account
special and
for me at least it's very similar to
what i might experience at my local our
ladies chapter
here is the most liked tweet of our
account thus far
and i think it's a little bit of both
it's explaining the package praise which
we got also a shout out
this morning at jenny bryan's keynote
and it's just a fun package that people
are
really excited to learn about
however not everything is fun right our
experiences are not only the fun stuff
but also the things that might be
frustrating about
our and we're all learning together and
no one seems to be an expert so
even our curators have questions one
tweet that i really liked was from cena
and she talked about her
frustration installing rcpp parallel
and basically every reply to this tweet
was i'm so glad i'm not alone
so if we look at a really quick
sentiment analysis of
um all of the tweets on this account we
have the most negatively charged words
on the
left and the most positively charged
words on the right we're a pretty
positive group i would say
um there are things that are negative
about the tweets in our account
primarily driven by like evil plots um
things like tricks and regression um
really really negative
conversely things that are positive um
is mainly because we love talking about
things that are shiny
so it's really interesting what comes up
when we do a sentiment analysis on this
but some of this jargon aside we're
still talking about issues get related
or not
mistakes and difficulties and in a
twitter world where everyone seems like
a superstar
this has been really comforting to me
and made the twitter community a little
bit more accessible
in the 2700 tweets that are currently in
this data set which doesn't even include
anyone this year
we've had about 400 plus questions and
counting maybe there's a little bit more
this was a quick
regular expression looking at all of the
tweets that contained question marks
and basically we're seeing that
everyone's asking questions whether
they're a student or a senior data
scientist
and these questions aren't only just
about our confusions they're just
they're also just engaging conversation
which i think is really really awesome
one tweet that i really love from my
friend kailyn
she asked people what they love about
data science and or statistics
and she also just gave her response to
this question as well
and the replies from this tweet were
just really really awesome and really
really encouraging
for someone who might be new to the
field
so i just want to end with maybe a
shameless plug
if you aren't following we are our
ladies in my unbiased opinion i think
it's worth following
and um if you are interested please just
consider curating for we are
ladies it doesn't matter whether you're
a beginner or whether you've
um whether you've been through
the ringer with r we're all learning
together and everyone's perspective is
valuable and this is something that i
really have found to ring true from
having to read every single tweet on
this account
so i just also want to close quickly
with some acknowledgements there's a lot
of
great people who make this broker happen
particularly
a huge thank you to the curators that
make it worth following week after week
thank you so much
you